You've lived your whole life in an
orphanage that's hiding a deadly secret.
What do you do when your world
is flipped upside down
and you realize you're destined to die?
There's no way outside of this place
and not a single person can be trusted.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do
and how to beat the Promised Neverland.
These kids are about to get
a brutal surprise.
Emma, here is an innocent 11 year old girl
while looking through this gate.
Her and two other kids
begin to wonder about what's outside
the concrete walls of their home.
The next day, she wakes up
to a bunch of kids running around a house.
These kids are all orphans
and none of them have ever seen
the outside world while messing about.
She bumps into a friendly woman
who they call mom.
The kids gather together and play a game.
But while playing, Emma and Norman here
reach a short gated fence.
According to mom, passing the fence
and leaving the orphanage is off limits
until you turn 12 years old.
The kids wonder about
what's behind the gate,
but they don't know that nothing
is beyond their other than certain death .
This adorable little girl is the next
lucky candidate to leave the orphanage.
All the kids say their goodbyes
before mom takes her away to the gates,
gathering in the food hall.
They noticed that the little girl left her
bunny toy behind,
being the nice children that they are.
These two run after mom
and the girl to give it back.
But the time they reach them,
they find the gates open and see a truck
looking in the back of the truck.
They find the same
little girl that just left.
But there's only one difference.
She's been brutally killed before.
They can even process what just happened.
Some deadly looking monsters
opened the gates nearby.
Well, Emma and Norman rush
under the truck.
They pluck the girl from the truck
and put her in some sort
of hibernation chamber.
Being only six years old,
she's regarded as average quality.
But the monsters are expecting some higher
quality, 11 and 12 year olds very soon.
It turns out this
orphanage is not for charity,
at least not for the kids listening in.
They realize their home is actually
an operation that raises the kids
until they're taken off
and eaten by these monsters,
which are referred to as demons.
Mom has been in on the whole thing,
working with the demons to raise
and feed the children to them.
The two kids escape back to the home,
but accidentally leave the toy
bunny onto the truck,
which is found by the demons.
And her mom now knows someone's
finally seen her.
Once again, I'm living a relatively
normal life and playing with my friends.
The next second, I see a cute little girl
decimated by some traumatizing creatures.
If I mama, I would honestly give it a day.
This orphanage is the only thing I've
ever known, and I'm only 11 years old.
Once the shock of seeing a six year old's
lifeless corpse has finally passed.
I would get to planning.
Obviously, something is seriously
messed up in this place,
and any adult I see can't be trusted.
The only adult in this place
right now is mom,
and she's been tracking us
our whole lives.
We should have known, though,
as far as that goes.
No kid has ever come back to say hello
or thank you for all the hard work
moms provide it with such a big orphanage.
I would be a little suspicious already.
This also raises another question
how is no one ever chased
after one of the kids
before this orphanage
seems to have been going on
for at least a decade,
and now we've just discovered that
our friends have been shipped off to die.
If I was a kid, I'd be running
after each and every
one of my friends to say goodbye.
How has no one ever seen
the insides of this gate?
Either way, these two kids have just had
their lives turned upside down,
waking up from a nightmare.
Imlay here has a completely new view
of the orphanage.
Emma and Norman realized that
all the regular school, like activities,
like exams and such, decide
who gets eaten first.
But no matter how smart or dumb
you are, after the age of 12,
everyone is sent off to death.
From past experience,
they figure out that every two months
another kid is sent off
being the responsible kids that they are.
They decide to make a plan to save
all the kids and escape the orphanage.
First off, we need to leave this place,
but we can't take everyone.
Some of these kids
have barely escaped the womb,
and there are no condition
to be running around the outside world.
According to early
developmental scientists,
children over the age of five
usually have nearly finished
cranial development and have some idea
of how to consciously make decisions.
So what I'm doing is telling all the kids
above and around the age of seven
and letting them know about
what I've just seen.
But we have to pick our words carefully.
We're dealing with kids, and kids
aren't too good at keeping secrets.
If that happens, I'm for sure being sent
off to demon hell and to never come back.
Seeing that I've been here my whole life,
I should know who I can and cannot trust.
I'm telling those
I trust about what I saw and making sure
they're not going to tell anyone else.
But the kids under seven aren't useless.
They can be used as bait
sets, mobs prepared to do
the most savage things to kill us.
We'll be doing the most savage
things to escape.
Looking at the gap between the bars,
it looks just a notch too small
for our 11 year old heads to fit through.
So that's where one of
the younger kids come into play
to make this as safe as possible.
We'll go during the night
when mom's asleep.
From there, we can use one of the kids
to walk around looking for a switch
or something to open the gates.
We seem to have about 25 kids.
Judging by how big the food hall is,
when the next kid is sentenced to death,
I'm telling all the younger ones
and the older ones
I trust to come with me on a trip.
I would try my best to keep the younger
kids oblivious to what's going on
because I'm such a nice guy.
When I reached the gate, I'm
instantly ditching the younger kids,
taking my friends
and sprinting to the other side.
We'll have 24 crazy
children running around,
which might be just enough
of a distraction for us to make it.
While it seems like a suicide mission
for the younger kids
and we don't know
what's on the other side of the gate,
it's better than voluntarily
getting ripped apart by horrifying demons.
They run to the outer
edges of the orphanage
and find a big concrete wall.
Mom reveals to the others
that she's holding a tracker,
that they make sure
none of the kids go missing
while they play.
Meanwhile, the two kids
find a massive wall
on the edge of the plantation
and make plans to scale it.
This quiet kid called Rey
finds them and asks what they're up to the
to explain themselves by telling him
what they saw the night before.
He's shocked, but he believes them
and agrees to team up
gathering in the food hall.
Mom introduced a new infant
to the family and a tall
lady who's probably in on the child
killing business as well.
A flashback of the two shows.
They're not good friends,
but simply business partners.
The tall lady is scheming to overtake her
and become her successor.
This new infant is shown
to have a scratch near her ear showing
where the tracking devices are stored.
OK, things just got a lot more difficult,
but we now know that we've been tracked
this whole time.
We don't know how it works.
But considering it, I can't imagine
it's as accurate as a smartphone
GPS, considering the fact that we've spent
significant time at the gates
and was sitting under the truck, either
mom's bluffing and waiting
for the perfect time to strike
or her device isn't as good as she thinks.
I would bet that her watch works
similarly to a compass
where she can only tell the direction
but doesn't have pinpoint
accurate location technology.
We can use this to our advantage
when planning our escape,
especially knowing that she doesn't know
who is on the tracker either.
Human microchips
are pretty high tech stuff.
So we have to assume that whoever
mom is, she's not working alone.
There must be some pretty costly backing,
especially knowing that since there's
a constant supply of food, clothing
and shelter to keep us safe.
Chips inside children, especially infants,
are currently unheard of.
So whatever technology these guys could
have could be something super advanced.
I would be inspecting
every single little precious kid
to see what the frech nuts is going on
with these trackers
and seeing if there's any way
I can manipulate them into breaking it,
depending on how deep the chip is.
And it doesn't look too deep.
It may be possible to kill it
with an electrostatic charge.
Well, we need to do
is to cut a hole in a piece of rubber,
a PVC pipe cut in on one end, wear
something like running shoes.
And you know what? Screw it.
Just take a knife
and cut the ear off of the precious child.
It's a lot faster.
I'm sure the kid won't mind
in order to train the children.
The three hatch a plan to play tag,
which works as a disguise
while they increase
the kid's fitness levels.
The tall lady jumps in as well and tells
the kids if they can hide for 20 minutes
without getting captured, they when she
turns out to be an expert athlete.
But Ray and Norment
managed to outrun her later that night.
The main three kids have a talk
and realize that one of the kids might be
a mole sending information to mom.
Things just got a lot more complicated.
The kids keep on training.
Meanwhile, Norman suggests
that they're leaving
debris in 10 days
instead of 45 days to trick mom later on.
The main three decide
they need to tell more of the kids
about their plans
to have a better chance of success.
Glasses, girl and the tocchet
are the next to be let in on the plan.
But Norman makes sure not to mention
anything about that kid dying earlier
to keep them from freaking out.
The search for the mall continues
with the kids laying a trap by leaving
a piece of rope in two different places
for mom to find suspecting
the new members.
Norman tells the two new recruits
different places where the rope is
if the rope is gone on the first floor.
The tall kid is the mole.
But if it's gone on the second floor,
glasses girl is the one.
The mole slips a note under mom's door.
Later on that night,
finding that the note is gone.
Ray and Norman dallied down to one person.
The mole is Ray.
Ray lets it out that he's the one sending
mom the group's information.
He confesses and lets Norma know
that he's been working with mom
for a number of years
to save himself from being killed.
He says he'll continue to help the kids
as long as Norman promises
not to save everyone.
He says it'll be impossible
for all the kids to make it and
all must be sacrificed
to ensure the success of the operation.
They both agree to the conditions,
but make a promise to not let Amma know.
Ray must be some sort of super genius,
or Norman must be a freaking idiot.
He's fooled all of us for the longest time
and managed to trick us even when we first
told him about our escape plan.
We know Ray is about 12 years old,
which means he's been working with mom
since he was pretty much
capable of thought.
If I'm Emma or Norman,
I'd be pretty doubtful of this guy now
We've all been microchip
and we don't even know what's inside it.
Mom could have some sort
of crazy technology
that lets her control her
every move and action.
He could be under mind control right now
for all we know.
We've seen crazier things happen
in the last few days,
but since he's already in front of us,
we should take some time
to pick his brain.
He seems like a really smart kid
and probably knows
more than any other child in this house.
The older five get together and figure out
there's a secret room.
Located imams room,
while most think it's too dangerous.
The tall kid here wants to find out what
happened to the girl who got taken away.
Him and glasses girl, go off to see
what secrets lay in the hidden room.
The main three find a few books
by famous author.
These books have hidden messages
covered in Morse code
that might show a way
out of the orphanage.
Meanwhile, tall boy and glasses
girl managed to get the key
to the secret room going inside.
They see the toys of all the kids
who were killed, while pretty disturbing.
They managed to also find a communication
device to the orphanage headquarters.
OK, this is a goldmine of information.
I didn't know before that there was
a massive library inside the house,
but I guess it makes sense
because we need to study.
It makes me wonder, though,
what exactly are we starting about?
I would take my time
and look through more of these books.
Books are knowledge
and knowledge is power.
I would find some books related to science
or history that could help us
escape this place
and also maybe a book on survival.
Maybe if I look hard enough,
I can find something
that might help us escape the operation,
like how to make a hang glider.
With this many books, there's bound to be
a whole boatload of useful information.
Even taking some time for
personal enjoyment wouldn't be a bad idea.
We've been under a lot of stress,
considering we don't have any technology
books is the next best thing.
Once we leave this place,
it'll be the first time in our lives
we'll have to fend
for ourselves after we leave.
It'll be our first time outside
books about survival and tips about how
to use the environment to our advantage
would be a literal lifesaver.
Realizing now that these toys mean
the girl from earlier is probably dead.
The tall kid angrily confronts
the main three about their whereabouts,
knowing there's no point in
hiding the truth.
They tell him about everything
that happened on that day.
The morning after Emma tells Norman about
her new plan to escape with all the kids.
Meanwhile, the tallboy steal
some chemicals to help the operation.
At the same time, Ray learns from mom that
he will be the next kid to be sent off.
The tall lady finds the kids
talking in the forest
and offers to team up, knowing
about their plans to leave the orphanage.
According to her,
if they escape, then mom will be fired
and she'll take her place in the orphanage
to gain their trust.
She tells them her history.
It turns out that the tall lady
was also an orphan,
then managed to survive
past the age limit.
However, if she leaves the surrounding
area, a chip inside her will electrocute
and kill her from the inside.
Now, that makes things more interesting.
Now all we have to do is fry her insides
and then she dies.
If she betrays us, that is knowing that
this lady's also been through the
same crazy shit that we have makes her
a little more trustworthy, in my opinion.
Before it looked like a bit of a trap.
But now we have some real power
on our side at this point.
We have all the information we need.
We've got books.
We've got a big powerful lady
and a bunch of kids who we can use
as meat shields if we want to.
I would propose an idea since we now know
one of the kids can pick locks.
We could ambush mom at night,
hold her hostage and use her as leverage
to leave the orphanage.
Mom seems like a valuable player
within this ecosystem of orphanages.
I would doubt they would just let her die.
Since the tall lady wants
her gone as well.
This is a win win situation.
She's got some dirt on mom.
And we can use that as an excuse
for doing all of this crazy stuff
if we have the tall lady
working alongside us.
She can pretend that
the kids are still in the house
while the demons open the gates.
Considering the fact
that there are endless trees and bushes
and it would be at nighttime,
I think the chance of escaping
would be pretty high.
From what we know about these demons,
which is not a lot.
They look pretty slow.
We've been training relatively hard.
And as kids, we have tons of energy
and it looks like we could outrun them
while not entirely trusting of her.
The kids and the lady
make an agreement to work together.
They meet in her room and question her
about the Demons headquarters.
She tells them getting rid of the tracker
will set off an alarm
and the only way to do
it is to cut their microchip ear off.
Well, what you look at that,
chopping your ears off, aren't I a genius?
While talking, it's obvious
that they still don't
completely trust each other,
but continue to cooperate.
Meanwhile, Ray gets a new camera
as a gift from mom for his hard work,
being the smart kids that they are.
They purposely hide some secret info
about mom for the tall lady to find.
The plan works as intended,
and she takes the letter without knowing.
Mom finds and tells her
that headquarters is sending her
to a different orphanage
and that she must leave today.
Going to the gates,
she meets the mysterious
lady called grandma,
who looks to be a rank above the mom's.
The tall lady tells grandma
about all the bad things
mom's done in the orphanage,
but it's all for nothing.
A demon comes out of hiding and grandma
reveals to her that her and mom
have been working together
this whole time by her command.
The tall lady is savagely
killed by the demon monster.
Meanwhile, in the house, mom gathers Ray
and tells him their partnership is over
before he can react.
She locked the door, trapping him
in the room, using the tracker.
Mom looks for Emma and Norman, who are
currently investigating the massive wall.
Luckily for Ray, the tall kid
finds him and knocks the door down.
While this is going
on, Mom finds the others trying to escape.
She catches them red handed and says that
they should just accept the fact
that their lives have been pretty good
so far and give up on leaving,
not agreeing with her statement.
Emma grabs mom and drags her down
while Norman grabs the ropes
to scale the wall out of rage.
Mom savagely breaks Emma's leg
before telling them that they need to.
As some of them are the best
meat in the orphanage,
the to stop resisting, and Norman is told
that he's only got one day left
before he must leave the orphanage.
You know what? Maybe she has a point.
We don't actually know
what our circumstances were before this.
We are orphans, after all.
There's likely a chance
that all of us were homeless
and would have died without mom.
And the demons help.
So at this point,
I would break out my puppy eyes and cry
and plead for her forgiveness
and say the mom is such a great figure
and maybe we can use our childlike naivete
and to trick her into thinking
that the escape is over.
Plus, Emma's leg is broken.
And as far as that goes, she's
now a liability for the group.
So I say we leave her and we'll survive.
Sorry, Emma. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
We all love Emma.
Mom does bring up a good point, though.
We need to think about what happens
once we get out.
For all we know,
there could be dangerous animals
and killer insects
crawling around everywhere.
We need to mentally
and physically prepare ourselves
for what could be a long journey
to civilization,
assuming we're not stranded
in a post apocalyptic landscape.
Once again, Emma's like
it's just been broken
and the tall lady just got murdered.
So we know mom is prepared to do
the most savage things
to ensure we're sent off to the demons.
Not only that, she's got to be
the most Two-Faced, no good nun lady
in the history of mankind, raising up kids
just to send them to death.
I love it. In the next scene,
Ray gives Norman a taser made by the parts
from mom's gift.
The three plan to use the Taser
to disable his tracker.
This gives Norman
time to hide in the forest
until they weed out the real escape day
because of this.
Ray will likely be the next
to go in his place to avoid this.
He plans to injure himself,
which will leave him unable to be shipped
off, as they only send the kids
if they're fully healthy
before they go to bed.
Ray decides to tell
the other two about his past.
It turns out that he knew about the demons
all along, as he does not experience
childhood amnesia. This means
that he retained all of his memories
dating back to when he was a baby.
He reveals that from a baby.
He was sent to the orphanage
and that beyond the gate
is the demon headquarters.
There are also five other plants which
have groups of kids just like theirs.
This also means that he's the only one
who has any idea of the outside world.
The next day, Norman goes to the gate
and manages to scale the wall
with the hidden ropes,
just barely managing to climb it.
He gets his first glimpse
of the outside world.
Sadly for him, there's only
one more obstacle.
There's a massive chasm
covering the outskirts of the wall
as an extra layer of protection.
While the plan was for him to hide
in the forest and wait out his deadline.
He decides to come back to the orphanage,
to the shock of absolutely everyone.
Well, there's a massive chasm,
which is a problem if I'm Norman.
I'm checking the area close to the gate.
Obviously, the gate wouldn't
lead to a massive hole as well.
There's probably a bridge
is something that would
easily lead out to the forest or something
easier to traverse.
Ray said that beyond
the gates is the demon headquarters.
But from this massive force landscape,
I couldn't tell you if that's true or not.
So I'm taking my chances either way.
Assuming there is, it's now go time.
Tonight, I'll be shipped off
to certain death.
I would wait till right after sundown
and assemble all the kids that are
fit enough, climb the wall
and make our way down to the bridge.
We don't know what's down there,
but there will be limited visibility.
There's also one more option.
We could zip line across this chasm.
We have some pretty dang long ropes
and we could combine them to at least see
if we can make our way across this chasm,
because I would rather not take forever
shaming our way down to find out
if this chasm was made by them or not.
Even with the massive gaping chasm, it's
not all that bad.
This is the first time
we've seen the outside world,
and it looks pretty much the same as what
we've always seen, trees and bushes.
This at least lets us know what we're
dealing with when we make our escape.
Later on, the three kids gather around
and figure out that
the area surrounding
the orphanage is shaped like a hexagon.
The only other way out,
other than somehow scaling the wall
and jumping over the massive
hole, is to go through the gate.
But obviously, if they go
through the gate,
most of them will probably get killed
and eaten alive by the demons.
To the shock of Emma and Ray, Norman
tells them that he never planned to escape
in the first place.
He just wanted to help them find out
more information about their surroundings.
He gives the Taser back
and gets ready to leave the orphanage,
saying his final farewells.
Emma, with a broken leg, tries to stop him
by breaking the tracker on his ear
before being pushed off. It's too late.
Norman goes off with mom to certain death.
However, this time, he's
not killed straight away.
Norman gets taken away to a side room
by the gate with a disturbed
look on his face.
OK, this is pretty bad
after all this hard work.
Looks like Norman either
gave up or never wanted to escape at all.
Before we can get too sad, we can think
about this from a positive perspective.
We now have two months
until another kid is gone.
That's a lot of time. And by the way,
we have a lot of kids.
For one, Norman told us we now know
it's possible to get on top of the wall
with a little athletic ability.
First thing we need to do
is to keep our training up.
Kids who are basic athletic level
naturally have higher endurance levels.
Then a lot of experienced endurance
athletes do due to fatigue resistant
muscles and the ability to recover
extremely fast because we're kids.
That means whatever training we do
is increased tenfold.
Once our fitness is sought,
it is time to escape.
I to make sure to bring enough food
and water with us to.
Last a few days,
even though to make it heavier
and running will tires out a lot faster.
The overall benefit of having it versus
not having it is clearly better.
Luckily, we know that most of the area
is forest, which means there's water.
Nearby forests are natural
filtration systems
which collect and produce
water year round.
We also need to know how to make a fire.
Luckily for us, all the materials we need
are right next to us by getting dry
wood twigs, bark leaves and a flint.
We can make a fire
that elastica us through the night.
And also, we will use the fire to sanitize
the water, killing any bacteria and bugs
that may be in the water,
knowing that Norman's probably dead.
The kids lose confidence
in the escape plan.
Ray tells the older kids that
he's accepted his fate and has given up.
After two months pass,
no progress has been made,
and it looks like
he will be the next to go.
The night before he sent to death
and shocks him by revealing she's never
stopped working on the escape plan.
Glasses girl and the tall kid
have been working with her
without suspicion of mom due
to their depressive moods.
Ray agrees that they should initiate
whatever operation they're attempting,
but he won't be a part of it.
He pours later fuel on his head
in an attempt to light himself on
fire, burning himself alive
along with the orphanage.
She manages to save him by catching
the lead in match and convinces him
to go along with their plan. Now
preparing to initiate the plan.
Ray cuts his ear off
with the microchip in it to track mom
into thinking he's stuck in the fire,
seeing his location still in the house.
Mom freaks out. He's
one of the highest quality suppliers
and attempts to extinguish the fire.
But it's too late.
She tries to access the hidden room,
but the keyhole has been filled.
The kids managed to make it
to the massive wall
and use their ropes to sell it to the top.
But Ray is shocked to learn.
Not all the kids have made it.
Mom grabs the communicator before
she watches the house burn in flames.
Standing outside,
a little kid comes rushing to her arms.
It turns out that the kids, less
than four years old, were left behind
in a genius play by Amite.
She realized that the kids
can only be sent out after turning six.
So she left them behind on purpose.
This is a win win situation.
The kids who are too young
would have probably had little chance
of surviving in the outside world.
And the oldest kid
still has about one and a half years left
until he or she sent off.
Since she's also determined to save them,
she plans to come back before any of them
have their sixth birthday.
That's pretty badass.
It's also probably the best plan
you could have made in this situation.
But I would disagree with coming back.
We now know how big this organization
is with multiple orphanages,
housing hundreds
or even thousands of kids.
We also know from the tall lady
they've been operating
for a long time, decades or even longer.
This means they have more power
than we can even imagine.
And I don't think it's possible
for us to get enough resources
in less than two years to save these kids.
Well, heartless, I would decide to
leave them behind because it's terrible.
We already have enough on our plate
with saving ourselves.
I would take the crappy option
and get as far away as possible
from this crazy orphanage.
Before that, though,
you know what I would do.
I wouldn't use all of the gasoline
up on the house.
Rather, I would set the whole farm
on fire as well.
The fire would likely kill mom
and all of the little ones,
but oh, boo hoo, cry me a river.
This woman has to be stopped
while the kids will die.
A pretty painful death.
This will stop mom from raising
more helpless kids to be eaten.
The wildfire would also serve
as an element of surprise,
showing headquarters that we mean business
and we are some kids
that are not to be messed
with with the younger kids safe .
Mom calls up headquarters and tells
the demons that there have been some
is somehow she manages to climb
the wall in time just before Emma crosses
the massive hole with a makeshift zip line
and an act of kindness.
She removes the pollies and wishes
the kids a safe journey and a sudden
flashback. Mom is shown to have been
raised in one of the orphanages herself.
But instead of being killed,
she was given the choice to become a mom
and begin her training
while becoming a mom.
She became a mom and gave birth
to a beautiful baby boy.
The kid she gave birth to was Ray.
While her child was taken away as a baby,
she remembers Ray as he often hums
the same song that she herself used to,
with Ray retaining his memories as a baby.
He also knows that mom is his mother
failing in her mission.
Mom goes back to the younger kids
and tells them that the older ones
have successfully escaped the orphanage.
The kids look onwards into the horizon
as they experience
the morning sun of their
very first day of freedom.
But if you don't want to end up
as a tasty demon
Happy Meal, I'd suggest you smash
that like button comment down below.
Let us know what you like, what you didn't
like, but be nice about it, OK?
And as always, do it
quick before mom gets. Yeah.